how are you looking forward to tonight
I'm gonna shame that you couldn't make
me film because it's urgently
difficulties as well I know and in the
CR I couldn't make it by two days and
just couldn't commit to two days and
then the show that I was doing got
canceled but I'm really really looking
forward to and I've I love the person
who's doing the was hoping to get so I
just think he's a great actor what makes
it so special working with jobs
I was basically he's he's a a writer
director who understands actors it's
extraordinary he has a wonderful way we
words and he he just he gets the best
out of everything
and I mean it's been a long as the
recognition of Joss Whedon has been so
long coming he's been I mean the the the
amount of work that he has behind him
that people just didn't just didn't you
know he's a huge fan boy found fandom
but for the you know for the
establishment to finally get it and this
this is that the icing on the cake this
this is so beautiful time
against the backdrop of the Avengers in
all that fantastic and one of the things
you for love you for obviously as well
as Buffy is Merlin now do you think I
know we've finished sadly now but do you
think we are any chance of having Merlin
the movie they talked about it but
they've now gone off to do something
else I have no idea I mean that if they
mooted it I'd always say yeah sure but I
think he kind of ran it ran its course
and they always intended to do over five
seasons and they kept their promise
what's been like stepping into Percy
Jackson for the Sea of Monsters that big
franchise movie
fantastic and it was it was it was great
to be a horse that really was cool and
it was a great challenge and I got to
wear blue tights and a very strange
little furry thing around my waist but
but you won't see that
you